[Música]
ó alegria estar aqui buscar ajuda
festa ruas esta rua fosse minha eu
mandava eu mandava ladrilhar com
pedrinhas com pedrinho de brilhante para
eu veio para ele o aluno pa
acho que a gente começava um programa
que eu coordenei por oito anos na
secretaria de estado da educação a os
nossos eventos com 1.200 professores
moisés professor porque esse programa
que acordei e que eu vou contar para
vocês essa história é um problema da
alegria um programa do dardo 2012 asma é
um programa do afeto é um problema do
acolhimento a sabiam e continuam sabendo
fazer educação que a educação não se
faça uma razão educação se faz também
com emoção tanto com a fé com a colina
eu vou com vocês deste programa que a
gente coordenou por oito anos
eu sou a fitch no corpo apaixonada pela
educação a coisa que eu fiz a minha vida
inteira e com mais ou menos a idéia eu
creio e que a gente se apaixona e não
deixa mais e eu ficou neste programa que
a gente vai contar pra vocês já depois
de aposentada porque eu já sou professor
a unidade já estava lá mas é é uma coisa
muito apaixonante
então a gente não deixa muito bem
em 2006 a secretaria de estado da
educação fez uma avaliação de como
estava o nível de alfabetização uns do
3º ano isto é crianças
oito anos no 3º ano um pouco mais talvez
alguns mais de oito anos
o resultado foi este membros da metade
de nossos alunos
sabe ler e escrever
depois de três anos na escola e ensino
fundamental
alguns até mais de 3 por que tinham
feito é infantil a pré-escola bom
um resultado que assustou com a
secretaria de educação e com certeza
estaria qualquer um de nós disse paulo
freire
eu não posso constatar uma realidade e
ficar acomodado não fazer nada para
transformar essa realidade
para mudar essa realidade é um dever
ético meu é um compromisso social de
todos nós e acha que eu tenho dito que
entendeu não não podemos ficar assim e
por uma decisão política de educação foi
dada prioridade absoluta à alfabetização
e letramento de nossas crianças dado do
estado de minas em 2006 porque eu tô que
estou aqui porque em 2006 e 2007 eu
recebi o convite da professora vanessa
que então é secretária de estado da
educação para vir ajudar a equipe para
estar junto com a equipe pra fazer
transformar essa realidade que a gente
que a gente constatou através de uma
avaliação externa feita pela
universidade federal de juiz de fora
pelo terceiro instituto chamado taag que
é o centro de avaliação educacional
muito perto
oito anos depois olha onde chega aos 8
anos
olha os avanços 48 quanto sem saber ler
e escrever aos em 2006
de um ano para o outro
a ida de 48 para 65 pontos sete a 12 17
e educação precisa de duas três gerações
para melhorar a a gente consegue
melhorar de manter o outro se trabalhar
muito se acolher bem os alunos se tem lá
os professores respeitando seus saberes
respeitando a sua experiência apoiando e
ajudando a escola e 2014 e 2013 14
saindo da secretaria em 2014
noventa e três por cento dos alunos de
nossas escolas sabiam ler e usá a a
leitura na vida cotidiana é na sua vida
a escola muito bem
os dados eram que que é da velha externa
da secretaria de educação feito grand
pelo caed ele ser comprovados pela
avaliação que o mec ministério da
educação faz e contínuo físico fazendo
através da prova brasil de 10 com minas
o olha como nós estávamos em 2007 o
brasil aqui e horta minas já acima da
média do brasil
começamos com o programa que em 2009
olha como avançamos e o brasil onde
ficou 2011 aqui
atingimos os 6 porto 6.0 segundo cd é é
um dado um resultado muito bom pra
educação um dos anos iniciais e em 2013
6.2 aí vocês podem perguntar mas o que
foi feito como é que vocês fizeram não é
bom
nós fizemos uma coisa que parece óbvia
mas que na realidade não é porque nós
fizemos colocamos o aluno a sua prende
szajman
o seu desempenho como cento do nosso
trabalho
tudo girava em torno do aluno todos
todos está trataria as 47
superintendências regionais que existem
no estado todo a escola os professores
todos ou a como centro pensar a gente
tem um discurso sobre isso todos nós
o aluno sujeito em deságio o aluno é o
coração da escola o aluno água
só que na realidade se a gente nesse
discurso mas vai na escola avalia e usa
quer aprender a ler e escrever não estão
retratos do terceiro ano
ele não é recente ea gente definiu ele
vai ter 60 muito bem nosso programa que
é um campus o programa de intervenção
pedagógica alfabetização no tempo certo
que todos conhecem como pitu ficou e se
essa filha é o p
ele ele tinha uma aspiração todos nós da
escola os professores durante esse
período todos nós queríamos todos a
mesma coisa toda criança lendo
escrevendo oito anos de idade
não podíamos continuar com aqueles
resultados não tinha condição e que não
é ruim para o aluno ruim para nós no
nosso estado rico do país não podia
aspirar a visão que nós tínhamos da
criança além do ipva em até 8 anos de
idade
e pra isso que nós
nós formamos uma equipe central que
estava na secretaria de educação que que
sob minha coordenação com a professora
vanessa secretária o homem era
subsecretário naquela elizabeth
espalhado por todos os 47
superintendências equipes regionais em
todas as superintendências também lá com
a sua coordenação
e essa equipe foi escolhida a dedo
pessoas com experiência com competência
em alfabetização e letramento pessoas
que estavam na escola vindo muito bem
esse trabalho que a gente trouxe para a
secretaria de educação
nós também vemos o vemos muitos
materiais para apoiar o professor guias
de alfabetização ebs para a gestão
pedagógica é cadernos de provas práticas
construídas com os professores enfim
toda uma série de materiais que estavam
à disposição do professor
nunca o brigávamos o professor a a
utilizar o que a gente colocava sua
disposição ele desse dia porque a gente
obriga as pessoas não há vontade aqui
professor se quiser pode usar mas todos
usavam porque o professor gosta de
coisas do material é muito bom muito
velho de metas incentivos isso isso foi
uma das maiores experiências mais
significativo da minha vida de educadora
porque que a educação a gente num agente
não tem utilidade muito com o número do
efetivo e preconceito o número dizia na
educação seed nomes mas na verdade os
duros nos ajuda a entender muito do que
curiosos sabe que eles não sabem
avaliação externa para nós foi muito
importante então nós definimos metas
para as escolas definirem metas para
super 10 e conjunto com eles e para o
estado e nós toas cumprir essas metas os
professores que deuses e quando a gente
cumprir a meta agentes e levava era
festa e os escolas gostavam e foi um
tempo de de trabalhar muito muito muito
firme e também de incentivos para quem
cumprir a meta é o que nós chamávamos
que o governo de minas chamou de prêmio
produtividade graças a deus a educação
sem cumprir as metas firmes o prêmio
produtividade muito bem e nós também
rio a formação dos nossos dos nossos
agentes pedagoga
todos estavam na escola na na área
pedagógica obviamente a prioridade na
formação continuada dos professores ea
formação dos professores é baseada na
nos resultados da avaliação externa
porque os alunos não sabiam fazer a
gente trabalhava com os professores para
que eles assinassem cada vez melhor os
alunos aprender e tínhamos também todo
um cultura de execução acompanhamento
dos deputados deste trabalho todo o
estado inteiro
depois descobrimos uma coisa muito
interessante a rede estadual onde o
programa acontecendo do pib aconteceu e
está acontecendo à verdes municipais mas
não no mesmo que a rede estadual
catarina já na segunda gestão à
professora ana lúcia gazzola ofereceu a
a a todos aos prefeitos e prefeituras do
estado todas as 853 municípios que
queriam do pipe todos para o outro olha
como está e 73 pontos seis vieram para
80 ponto a diminuir indo à distância que
existia entre redes municipais e
estadual em 2011 foi 2013 e 2011 a
secretária também à luz a a ampliou o
programa para os anos finais do ensino
fundamental e assim como nos anos
iniciais sempre fomos os primeiros do
brasil também com um ano de trabalho nos
anos finais passados também um ã o
primeiro no brasil porque a gente
melhorou porque a gente conseguiu isso
tudo tínhamos uma visão como todo mundo
queria que os alunos aprendessem tipo
indicado terna ano para dedicar se a
gente estava melhorando está bem
actuamos metas com as escolas e as
pessoas iam cumprir as metas e celebrar
nós diminuímos as distâncias entre
secretaria de educação e escola
secretaria de educação e
superintendências quando as meninas da
nossa equipe equipe maravilhosa chegava
nas escolas lá no norte de minas
jequitinhonha
as diretoras porque a gente da
secretaria está aqui no acreditado
porque não era não era comum discutidos
e que nós tínhamos uma estrutura de
gestão orientação acompanhamento de uma
formação continuada dos professores que
que acontecia todo ano sistematicamente
não era uma fumaça hoje não era um
sistema de formação continuada dos
professores muito como nos ensina paulo
freire ilha caminha sem aprender a
caminhar que vai aprender a fazer o
caminho e anos e até fazendo retocando
só entre a gente começou a caminhar
é isso que a gente fez nós tínhamos um
sonho tínhamos uma visão tínhamos uma
inspiração em desviar do caminho todos
juntos diretores professores
especialistas é consultoria e prezado
gem muita gente que nos ajudou ea gente
cresceu junto neste programa
como bons os mineiros nossos povos disse
guimarães rosa na serra vez sendo agora
minas entende atende toma tempo avança
ter eja e faz nosso exemplo uma grande
equipe
fizemos o pito acontecer dos nossos
meninos aprender no tempo certo a ler e
escrever a letra
[Aplausos]